hello
danemarkland
it's wonderful to be here has everyone
had a fantastic week
yes
excellent glad to hear it uh i would
just like before i start to say thank
you to uh jacob and kirsty and steiner
and henriette and all the volunteers uh
the people in the green t-shirts who've
been sort of
marshalling the rooms and gathering the
feedback and everything there's a lot of
work that goes into these conferences so
can we have a round of applause for all
the people who make this happen
so i'm gonna finish things off you're
all tired it's been a long week you've
got loads of information to process and
so i'm just gonna basically share some
very silly stuff there may accidentally
be some lessons in there that you can
learn i apologize
uh
but this is all about
some some mistakes and the kind of
mistakes that are made by software
developers and engineers
before i start content warning there is
going to be swearing
i am going to say [ __ ] quite a lot just
in the next segment but it is relevant
to the plot
and
so that is justified what i am not going
to be talking about in this talk because
it's light-hearted it's designed to make
you laugh i'm not going to be talking
about any situations where software
errors have actually killed people
but software errors have killed people
okay so yeah but there's none of that in
here this is all just it basically cost
a lot of money for the most part or um
cost me my job in in what some cases
so yeah
and this is
me this was one of my biggest mistakes i
worked for a software company and this
was when i was in my 20s i was young i
was arrogant i thought i was like a 10x
developer and hot [ __ ] and all that sort
of stuff and i worked at this company
and also in my defense before we get
into this i was already spiraling into
what would eventually become a full-on
nervous breakdown so i wasn't
necessarily thinking straight
our company we sold event management
software and membership software and it
was very complicated and you could build
these huge complicated queries across
the database and you could save those
queries into a file so you could load
them again the next day and those files
had a med extension i can't even
remember what it stood for but we called
them med files
and we released an update to the
software and it corrupted when you saved
the med file it corrupted it and so the
support people
came to me and they said and i quote
mark the med files are [ __ ]
can you write something to unfuck the
med files
and so i went into visual studio and i
did file new project and i said what's
the project name and i went oh um [ __ ]
[Music]
and so i created this little cons this
little uh windows application uh windows
forms application
and it displayed a dialog box
and it said
choose file to unfuck
and you clicked a button
and it you went off and you browse and
you chose your file and then it had a
button that said unfuck now
and then it ran it through its thing it
did its thing and then it displayed a
message box that said med file
successfully unfucked
close
and it worked i thought it worked but
you know support had a bunch of support
were also qa it was that kind of company
and so i gave the application which was
called unfuck.xi
to the support person who had reported
this to me and i went can you test this
out and make sure it works and then we
can clean it up and send it to the
customer i don't know if he tested it
i can't imagine that he did
because then without coming back to me
he shipped it to the customer
and they ran it
and
yeah it doesn't look particular these
are the kinds of customers who are
paying you half a million pounds a year
on a sort of support subscription basis
and we send them a file called
unfuck.exe that says your file has been
unfucked
and at the time
i was in such a bad place mentally i
blamed the support guy
for this because i obviously got hauled
across the coals for this
and i blamed the support guy for
shipping the thing whereas obviously it
was actually my fault i should never
have created a program called unfuck.exe
that was just not a good idea it's okay
to swear in comments
um as long as you're never going to open
source things but but don't actually put
unfuck
on a slightly related note by the way
when i very early in my career
did anyone any windows 3.1
veterans in the room so windows 3.1 it
was a file called win.com and every
message uh and every piece of text that
could be displayed in windows was
embedded in wind.com just as text and if
you used a hex editor you could open it
up
interesting trivia
the phrase general protection fault
has one more character than the phrase
mongolian [ __ ]
and so if you put two spaces in the
middle you can edit someone's win.com
file and then you can run away
and then the next time that happens they
will get a message box that says a
mongolian cluster [ __ ] has occurred
which has caused your application to
terminate
one of the worst things about windows 11
is you can't do that anymore
okay let's talk about y2k everyone knows
about y2k um that was probably one of
the biggest mistakes in software but it
wasn't that we let that happen in the
first place it was really to do with
how slow we were in fixing it because
what you have to understand about the
people who wrote the code that then
caused the y2k problem was that this is
what data was stored on at the time
punch cards so every column on there is
basically a byte of information and so
those extra two digits on the year would
have been an extra two columns on there
multiply that by a million bank
customers and a hundred million
transactions a day and those extra two
columns add up to a lot of extra punch
cards
and memory in those days this was what
memory looked like in those days this
isn't under a microscope this is just a
photograph that
is core memory and it's lots of magnetic
poles and through each pole two pieces
of wire have been passed these were made
by usually women with microscopes and
needles memory in the 1950s was knitted
and
core memory cost about a dollar a bit
so a bite of memory would cost you eight
dollars you think like that means a
kilobyte of memory would cost you eight
thousand dollars so memory was was
really at a premium and uh this is also
incidentally why uh unix still says core
dump to this day it's because it was the
core memory that was being dumped
and of course in those days it was just
a kilobyte and it was quite easy to read
through
so early programming languages like
cobol they didn't think in bytes they
thought in bits and so this is the uh
definition for a date variable um and we
say this is a it's a
a string type variable but
the nine means it's a number character
and so it can only be naught to nine or
some of the other like hyphen and comma
and dot and things like that so that
would fit in six bits instead of eight
bits which meant you saved a couple of
dollars every time you were putting one
of these things into memory so it was
quite reasonable to shorten the date and
only use the the sort of decade and the
year
this is um i've forgotten his name
uh bob beamer
and bob beamer in 1954
was the guy going i i realized we have
to do this but as soon as memory becomes
cheaper we really should change that to
a pick eight
pick nine eight because this is going to
cause a problem 1954 he said that
in 1964 he started saying it with a
little bit more emphasis
in 1974 he started shouting about it
in 1984 he was giving talks at
conferences going guys we really really
need to fix this in 1994 after bob bemer
had retired
we actually started work on fixing it
and by that time
all this software had carried on you so
you wrote new bits of this software and
you carried on using that and so the
effort to stop the y2k bug from
happening was ridiculous and it took an
awful lot of people an awful lot of time
but we did it
and then the year 2000 came
and there were very few big computer
crashes and no airplanes fell out of the
sky and all this sort of stuff and the
whole of the rest of the world went well
that y2k thing was a lot of nonsense
wasn't it what a fuss
and people like me who'd rewritten cobol
systems in infamyx4gl to fix this when
no you're welcome
yeah it's it's like yeah yeah no it's
thanks to me your hospital still works
but no
bob beamer uh died in 2004 um so he did
actually get to see the the problem
being fixed but the estimated cost of
fixing the y2k bug goes from some people
say 300 million dollars some people say
800 no 300 billion dollars
some people say 800 billion dollars so
let's put it somewhere in the middle
we'll say it cost half a trillion
dollars to fix the y2k bug
and you'd think we'd learn from that and
we wouldn't set ourselves up for any
other y2k bugs particularly if you're
like one of the biggest software
engineering companies in the world you
wouldn't put something into say your
flagship email server
that was going to break at a no no no
microsoft this happened this year
a
thing that microsoft was storing in an
integer ticked over uh i don't know what
exactly what the number was but suddenly
we couldn't convert this number to a
long uh because it was too big and
exchange servers all over the world
including office 365 just choked and
died and microsoft had to hurriedly roll
out a fix for that
in the year 2038
there's the apocalypse is coming eunuch
still stores the system date and time as
the number of seconds since uh january
the 1st 1970 um in a signed 32-bit
integer and that's going to crash in
2038 and you'd think well that's an easy
fix change it to a 64-bit integer but no
they've patched it with an extra bit so
now they've got a 33-bit integer which
kicks the can down the road
until like the year 42 something but
you know
linux gonna linux
my favorite one of these though is the
dog 38 bug that the kennel club of the
united states of america have so the
kennel club um your dogs are categorized
by their pedigree breed and then your
dog has a name and it's one of those big
long show names like
like i have a pedigree dog and her i
can't remember her show name it's got
something sugar cookie something
something
um and so
uh if they already have a dog with that
name which is obviously a big country
300 million people lots of dogs it
happens and so they they number them and
so yeah one two three four five six blah
blah thirty-seven and if you go to i had
a dog and there were already 37 dogs of
that breed with that name and so this is
dog number 38 it crashes because it
can't write the number into the database
see if you
can anyone guess how they're writing the
number into the database that would
cause 37 and all the numbers up to 37 to
be okay
and 38 suddenly crashes
roman numerals
they store the roman numerals in a char
6 field
and every number up to 38
so 38 is xxx v
uh
37 sorry is x xx viii
um all the numbers before that fit in
fine but 38 is xxx v i i i and this one
i really don't understand it's going to
the database change it to a
char 8 or you know god forbid an integer
and just
format
someone just went i i can't write the
algorithm to format a number as roman
numerables let's just store it as roman
numerals so yeah that's fun um i would
like to thank standupmaths on youtube
great channel and i found that one on
there as i was writing this talk so that
was interesting
a lot of this actually comes down to
one of our biggest mistakes in program
which is just enterprise programming
generally enterprise software it's just
you know
the the processes and the procedures and
the waterfall and the project planning
five years in advance and all this sort
of stuff and it causes problems and you
can see the kinds of problems that it
causes um so yes enterprise a business
plan or project especially one that is
difficult
or may fail or lose money and everything
in enterprise development is based
around this it's nothing to do with
building good software it's nothing to
do with working efficiently it's all to
do with covering your ass so that when
the thing goes wrong at the end of the
day you still get paid because you can
prove it was somebody else's fault
which is why you get agile development
uh posters that look like this this is
the scaled agile framework for
enterprise this is the simplified
version
there are worse versions than this
and you get things like this autoscrum
1.1 which is accentures this is still
claiming to be agile this is accenture's
agile framework that they use
and
somewhere in there
we have a program backlog we've got us
oh yeah we do we have a sprint right
down there there's a daily scrum um and
i think i think they've allocated some
time for people to write code
i'm not sure
people have probably seen this this is
deloitte's agile landscape version three
the terrifying thing with this
is that this and this
are just single dots on this
and and we wonder
why so many enterprise projects fail
quick story about enterprise i worked uh
i was hired by one of the national um
agencies the the quangos as we call them
quasi-autonomous non-governmental agency
organization
um in the uk they had and then an api
endpoint only had one thing and it just
returned uh a list of the amount of
energy that was being used in the uk
right at that second and that is very
useful information
if you're investing in energy futures
you want to watch those patterns and so
people just kept hitting it and hitting
it and hitting it it didn't have ip
throttling it didn't have any accounts
or anything like that it was an
anonymous end point and you hit it and
it did a quite complicated database
query against an oracle database
and did people put a thread.sleep10 or a
task.delay10 in between no no no no they
just get it hit it again hit it again
um they had this running on one 32-bit
server it was written in net 2.0 i had
been brought in to look at this in 2014
and
uh yeah it was 32bit.net so it didn't
have much memory the oracle database was
also 32-bit running on an old server the
servers had been there since like 2005.
so they were well past their death um
time and uh yeah they said can you take
a look at this code and tell me what's
wrong with it and tell us how to fix it
and i went
i could just fix it and they went no no
no don't fix it
we give you two weeks to write a 20-page
document telling us how to fix it and so
i took it back to the office and i
loaded it into visual studio and
resharper actually started crying
um
and then uninstalled itself
and when no you're on your own
just just don't
and basically i don't i don't do
planning i don't do documentation i
don't do that sort of thing i'm getting
better at it now as i get older and more
responsible but back in those days come
back what i'm going to do i'll fix it
and then i'll just write down what i did
to fix it and actually the main thing i
did to fix it was where they said var
connection equals
oracle
database connection new oracle db
connection i just added using because
they weren't disposing their their
database connections so it crashed every
20 minutes because they exhausted memory
and the app pool had to recycle um and
so i
managed to
write 20 pages on why using statements
are important
sent it back to them didn't hear
anything from them for nine months and
then they came back to me and and they
said can you come in for a meeting to
discuss your findings i'm kind of like
you haven't done it yet
so i go off and my boss goes up and um
i'm he's charging them 2 000 pounds for
me to be there for the day lord knows
what you charged for him to be there for
the day i'm guessing about 5 000 pounds
we get there there's 10 ibm consultants
sitting around this table and i know
that ibm consultants are about 10 000
pounds a day
so this is a hundred thousand pound
meeting that's happening right here and
and i go look i've actually if i can
give you the code i've brought it on a
usb if you want the fixed version of the
code it's here and i would recommend
running it on in 64-bit
on a server that isn't 10 years old but
this will probably still work even if
you don't do that and they went yes we
can't just go in willy-nilly and fix it
and put it on new servers this is a
critical system
yes it's a critical system that crashes
every 20 minutes
and is is costing you an absolute
fortune um and
just just buy a new server just put it
on a new server and it will be better
but give it 64 bits and give it like 16
gigs of ram and it will run smoother
well we can't just you know that has to
go through a whole process and i'm like
this meeting is costing a hundred
thousand pounds
and for a hundred thousand pounds you
could buy a data center and run this
thing on a server farm and it would be
fine and my boss went uh mark why don't
you go outside and get some fresh air
and so i go out and i wait by his car
and he's kind of i'm just uh i'm in so
much trouble i'm gonna get sacked again
um
and i'm smoking a cigarette because i
smoked at the time um and he comes out
and i'm like i'm really really really so
anywhere no don't worry about it i'll
turn the [ __ ] off
we don't need that [ __ ] he said
okay
this was a fun one so
problems in software they're easy to fix
so you've pat you shipped some software
that doesn't work and they are it
doesn't work and you go here's a new
version of the software intel managed to
get a software bug into their processor
so the pentium chip was the first intel
processor that actually had a floating
point unit built into it before that we
had the 486 and there was a 487
coprocessor that did floating point but
intel had combined it into the actual
chip itself
and the pentium floating point unit
accelerated floating point operations
there you go that's what it looked like
so what is four million one hundred and
ninety five thousand eight hundred and
thirty five divided by three million one
hundred and forty five thousand seven
hundred twenty seven it's one point
three three three eight two except
according to the intel pentium's
floating point accelerator it's 1.33374
and
there were a few instances where this
would go wrong and people noticed and
intel went okay if you can prove that
you are actually affected by this bug we
will just send you a new intel pentium
processor where it is fixed and then so
many people came up with these torturous
this is why it's not working for me
which were largely to do with microsoft
excel
and so intel ended up going fine just if
you've bought a pentium we'll send you
another pentium and that ended up
costing intel 475
million dollars to fix
i'm not sure anything like it's happened
since i would imagine they probably run
every possible floating point
calculation as part of their unit tests
null
this is quite famous um null and we
actually have a fairly easy value to
assign to null because tony hawe who was
the guy who invented null has called it
his billion dollar mistake
so tony haw he's a british computer
scientist hugely respected he's like a
knight or a kbe or something of the
british empire um and he was working on
al gold w and our goal w was the first
uh
programming language that introduced the
concept of records what we think of as
like classes or structs or whatever and
so you had a record that was a person
which had these things in here and so
when you've got records you need
references to where that record is held
because now it's a collection of data
stored on a heap and so you see here
person has a reference to another person
which is their father mother youngest
offspring or elder sibling and so where
you've got references what do you do if
there is no father mother youngest
offspring or elder sibling and so tony
hall went well we'll just call that null
and so we say if p equals null then m
otherwise if m equals null then p
otherwise do something with p and m and
and we'll return that back
um and at the time that probably seemed
perfectly reasonable but ever since then
uh hands up who has not ever had a null
reference exception in net or java or
any language they've ever programmed in
or um
or javascript undefined does not have a
method index of or whatever it is
javascript says
so yes and tony hawk calls that his
billion dollar mistake and and will
quite happily tell you all about it
there's a video on youtube of him doing
a one-hour talk at a conference about
how null happened and why it was a bad
idea
hartford center sometimes
software problems actually cause other
problems in the real world so the
hartford center was built in the 1970s
and it was one of the first buildings
that was uh designed using a software
cad package a computer-aided design
package and back in those days there was
no autocad there weren't these
high-level things a cad package the
engineer and architect using it would
actually program in the algorithms the
formulas for the stresses on various
beams and all this sort of thing and
they built the hartford center and it
was fine but the hartford center i think
it's in connecticut it's somewhere in
the united states it snows it snows a
lot and the hartford center was fine
until one night it snowed a lot and this
happened
fortunately no one was in the building
at the time there had been a concert and
everybody had left the building about
four hours before this actually happened
and the problem was that they put in the
calculations for the beams on how much
the stresses on them were going to be
but what they didn't account for was the
roof is slanted like this and you people
in scandinavia you'll know what happens
to snow when it lands on a roof it kind
of evenly distributes itself like this
and then it warms up a bit and it goes
and they hadn't accounted for the
horizontal tolerances on these beams and
so it did that and a beam sheared
sideways and then that being sheared
sideways and then the entire roof
collapsed just because of one error in
programming a cad package
that cost them 90 million dollars to put
a new roof on the hartford center that's
not too bad
this one's fun
night capital i like this one because
night capital are a hedge fund and i
don't like hedge funds
although if you work for a hedge fund
and you need some consultancy i will
happily come and consult for you and my
rates are very reasonable by hedge fund
standards
certainly compared to night capital what
you have to understand about hedge funds
is the stock market the first stock
market was created by the dutch east
india company they needed to raise money
to build ships to go to india to steal
stuff and bring it back to europe to
sell it and so the way they did this was
they said we'll sell shares in the
expedition and we go and we steal the
stuff and we bring it back here and then
we sell it and then how you get your
percentage of our profits that we make
from doing that and then other people
that's a brilliant way to raise money to
start a company i'm gonna do that as
well and then 400 years later somehow
that had turned into highly optimized
programs running in dark pools trading
with each other at microsecond levels
skimming fractions of a fraction of a
cent off the top of the transaction to
try and make rich people richer while
the rest of us got poorer and this is
what knight capital were doing
and
in 1996 this was all happening in these
things called dark pulls so the hedge
funds and the investment banks and
everything created their own sort of
shadowy stock markets where they could
do this and the new york stock exchange
went we are missing out on so much
commission we're going to create our own
light pull and so they did and they
called it the retail liquidity program
and so everybody had to scramble to get
their algorithms and their programs that
were running in the dark pools to run on
the new york stock exchange's
retail liquidity program and so night
capital basically copied and pasted a
bunch of code around the place and
dragged in some modules and all this
sort of stuff and threw it into this new
retail liquidity program with about two
weeks notice
and and it went in there and it started
running and within uh four minutes it
had spent a billion dollars
and when they deployed it it was running
on eight servers and the deployment
rolled out but it only worked on seven
of the servers and the eighth server
continued running this old um code that
was the buggy code
and so they went oh no it's spending too
much money a fail safe that was supposed
to trigger wasn't working because it
came from a different system and the
flag wasn't getting set and whatever was
going on and they went well it must be
um that this new code has got a bug in
it so we'll roll it back and they said
copy the code from the eighth server
onto the other seven servers that'll fix
it
by 28 minutes past nine on the morning
that this thing went live their
algorithm had spent seven billion
dollars
and
night capital didn't have seven billion
dollars and the rule is you have to
settle within 48 hours and so they had
to uh essentially bail themselves out so
they sold all their positions this
entire seven billion dollars worth of
positions to goldman sachs for 450
million dollars
um 440 million dollars
um so yeah uh and then the following
year they were acquired in a hostile
takeover by goldman sachs um who kind of
went yeah you really shouldn't be
allowed to do things
that's fun i like it when hedge funds
lose money how are we doing halfway
through good stuff
so
bugs in space
like pigs in space from the muppets but
bugs in space
um
there have been lots of bugs in space
and bugs in space are difficult because
you can't sort of attach you can't go
how is this going to work in space i
know i'll go into space with my laptop
and set a break you can't do that
laptops don't do well in space for a
start so yeah
so just a few of these mariner 1
this was one of nasa's very first
missions um and the computers in those
very very basic and so programming was
taking mathematical formula and turning
them into machine code i don't think
there was even assembly language really
for these guys and so
they would take the mathematical formula
and literally kind of just go okay so
that would be this and this and this
and
this is what mariner 1 would have looked
like if it had ever made it to space
but it didn't and it wasn't the
programmer's fault it was the the
mathematician's fault he gave the
programmer a formula that had an r in it
and it should have been the r on the
left with a hyphen over the top of it
and what the hyphen means is smoothed
over a period of time so we sort of it's
going to spike up here and down here and
down here and but what we want is kind
of the average over the previous like 20
samples of whatever this is but he just
left out the hyphen and so they used r
and so if you've got a value where it's
supposed to be zero and kind of plus one
or minus one is probably okay plus two
minus two is probably okay
but plus eight is a very bad idea indeed
and you're not smooth eo so eight and
then back down to zero and then minus
eight and back up to zero it's probably
okay that's probably normal but they
thought what they were getting was the
average smoothing and so when it came
through as eight the guy in mission
control went bang and hit the button
that blew up the rocket on purpose
so um
yeah
if anyone was in martin thwaites's uh
talk on open telemetry or any talks
about tracing or metrics or anything
like that it's really important to make
sure that the data your telemetry data
is accurate um and that you're getting
out the number that you think you're
getting out because otherwise you blow
up your spaceship and then you have to
build another one for 18 million dollars
in 1960s money which is closer to 80
million dollars today
you think actually the the mars the
mariner one mission um is credited that
missing hyphen is credited with the
creation the inspiration of software
engineering as a discipline that was the
point at which people went hey maybe we
should do like what those engineers do
when they build bridges and you know
bridges have collapsed and stuff but
that was when we kind of started
applying engineering principles to
building software which did not save the
mars climate orbiter
which had a similar experience although
it did get most of the way to mars to be
fair the rocket took off it got it into
orbit it set its engines going and it
got to mars and then it crashed into
mars crashed into the surface of mars at
a very very high velocity and there's
there's still a scar that you can see
from one of the other orbiters that went
up there and the reason for this is
incredibly simple it's because americans
are stupid
and americans insist on using inches
instead of centimeters
now nasa are not stupid nasa use
centimeters for everything actually they
use millimeters for everything so nasa
is like millimeter scale stuff so
they don't say um a centimeter they say
10 millimeters because they work with
the european space agency they work with
ross cosmos they work with the chinese
they work with space agencies all over
the world they work with suppliers all
over the world you have to be using the
same units and everyone on the mars
orbiter mission was using the same units
everyone was using millimeters and
centimeters except lockheed martin
lockheed martin we're using inches
so to give you a visual idea
if this is me at five centimeters tall
then this is me at five inches tall it's
quite a big difference inches are not
centimeters and so when the mars climate
orbiter arrived at mars its planned
trajectory was that it should have gone
into orbit at 226 kilometers above the
surface of mars and what it actually did
was go into orbit 57 kilometers above
the surface of mars which meant it got
caught in mars gravity and smashed into
it so yes units are important it's one
of the one of the good things about f
sharp is the whole units of measure
thing can we get that in in c sharp at
12 or something that's you know you're
copying everything else from f sharp so
so awesome having you in the room to say
that
okay
um it's not just nasa though um so yes
327 million pounds dollars for the mars
climate orbiter uh plus the 18 months
that it takes the thing to get to mars
and then kind of going that didn't work
should build another one
but the french the european space agency
um has has problems with their own uh
this is the ariane 5 launch
um
and ariane this is the first ever launch
of ariane 5 and it was a mission called
cluster it had four european space
agency satellites on it
and the the tests had all gone perfectly
the the the pressure testing and
everything and then it took off and it
soared majestically into the sky
and then some code that they had copied
and pasted from the ariane 4 control
software
tried to write a 64-bit floating point
number into a 16-bit uh integer variable
and this caused the boosters on one side
to adjust their vertical their
horizontal thrust um a lot and so the
boosters split off the rocket
and
that happened
and uh yeah this was spectacular there's
actually there's a talk kind of similar
to this one by kevin henny where he goes
into a lot more detail and he has the
code and it's on youtube so you can
track that down if you want to know
exactly what happened there but
basically
they had they had seven variables that
controlled the the flight path um to get
into orbit and four of them were guarded
so if you try to write the wrong kind
into one wrong type of data into them
you wouldn't be able to um the that one
the the one there that caused that that
wasn't guarded because guarding a
variable
uses quite a lot of something and they
didn't think they could spare it and so
yes
spectacular ariane 5 though i mean you
know since then ariane 5 has been an
absolute workhorse and it's put so much
stuff into orbit and it's going to have
to keep doing it for quite a while
because ariane 6 has just been delayed
again
enterprise
half a billion dollars the ariane 5
disaster
that's that's kind of probably
exaggerated but um yeah it's it's sort
of including missed missions and people
saying oh no you're not launching our
satellites we're going to take these to
nasa you can sort off
so yes
um the big rewrite
this was me
um this is one another one of my
mistakes
uh same company with medford unfucker
actually we had a product that was
written in a language called gupta
sequel windows and it was dying and i
was can we rewrite it in net please i've
just this i've got this new.net thing
it's brilliant can we rewrite and they
said yeah all right and so i started
rewriting the entire application as a
windows forms application
um and they had four people working on
the old application and me working on
the new one
and so they were adding features and
doing all that and i was trying to catch
up to them but i was i was getting there
and it was okay and then 2005 2006 came
along and microsoft released wpf
and it was new and improved and i was
going oh no it's a new thing windows
forms is dead wpf is so much better and
the binding works better and the design
is lovely and all this sort of stuff
it's a shiny thing i want the shiny
thing and so i decided that i was going
to throw out all the windows forms code
and and replace it with wpf and that did
actually cause me to have a nervous
breakdown and take six months off work
um and then when i got back to work they
did a performance review and they gave
me a five which was the worst you could
get and i went why and they said well
you just took six months off
so yes
um new and improved do not just go ah
anything and rewrite everything because
you think it looks cool um probably it
only cost them a hundred thousand pounds
in terms of what they'd paid me to
achieve precisely nothing uh but it did
also cost me my sanity um and
the the main sort of thing i got out of
it is i know not to do that again
um
recursion
uh this is just a little bug bearer of
mine um i happen to read something about
recursion and how recursion is a better
pattern than loops and i just it's a lie
effectively recursion is loops it's just
a different way of doing it so if you
recurse in a normal application you will
end up getting a stack overflow error
because things go round and round in
circles and every time it pushes
something onto the stack until there's
no room left on the stack and so to
avoid this there is a thing called tail
call elimination where the compiler
recognizes that that's what you're doing
and eliminates that tail call and make
something happen in a different way
so to avoid this stack overflow
exception
so
if you look at this
this will eventually cause a stack
overflow because this is 32-bit
x86.net framework doesn't do tail call
elimination and so the jit just produces
this code here uh which calls countdown
and calls countdown so if you call this
with a big enough number like in 32.max
value you will get a stackoverflow
exception
with the 64-bit jit they introduce tail
call elimination and so that produces
this code and you can see l 0 0
l 0 0 14 jump l 0 0 0 7. so every time
someone goes oh recursion is a far
superior and computer sciencey and and
functionally way of doing loops point
out to them that that's a go-to
and i can prove it's a go-to
because there's the same code written
with a go-to and
yeah look there you go we've got jump
shaw lw it's a little bit different
um but it's uh one less instruction than
the recursion version and we do our jump
short l07 um at the end there and yeah
so recursion can go jump in a lake as
far as i'm concerned um i would like to
thank
andre
ashmined on twitter for sharplab.io if
you've never seen sharplab.io and you do
c sharp development um it's brilliant
you paste some c sharp code into it
it'll show you
the c sharp compilers sort of
the c-sharp that it generates for your
properties and async methods and the
state machine and all this sort of stuff
it'll show you the il that's generated
and then it will show you the actual
machine code that's generated by the jit
it's fantastic javascript
any javascript fans in the room are
about to upset anybody because this this
really was it was a mistake
it was one of the biggest ones and the
thing is
it was netscape version two
and somebody stuck their head around
brendan ike's door and went brendan can
you knock up a quick language that we
can stick in the next version of our
browser so that when you put the mouse
over an image we can change it to a
different image all right cheers how
long
a week cool
and so a week later brendan goes back
with scheme basically because if you
need to implement a programming language
in a week then you write a lisp because
they're the easiest programming language
to implement so hey we've got scheme to
run in the browser and they went oh no
no nobody does lisp anymore no we don't
like all those parentheses you know
what's really hot at the moment is that
java thing why don't you make it look
more like java and so rather than sort
of patch the holes and the problems and
everything else brendan made his scheme
look like java which involves changing
prefix operators to infix operators and
that sort of stuff
and the other thing was they wanted it
to be possible so the kind of people who
were just hand coding html and creating
personal home pages could hand code some
javascript to achieve these effects and
so they put all sorts of things in there
to try and help
these developers like if you said if
this thing is equal equal to this thing
and they were two different types then
javascript would go well what if i made
them the same type and then come that
would work wouldn't it yeah yeah yeah
that would work
and and we ended up with this absolute
abomination of language but the biggest
problem of all
is that it shipped
and then people started using it
and they can't you can't fix it you
can't fix double equals in javascript so
we have triple equals and bang double
equals
and apart from anything else that's
wrong
so it's it's just it should be bang
triple equals or i don't know
but anyway i just think if someone had
poked their head around brendan ike
store and said hey brendan can you
create the language that will be used
for 90 of all programming over the next
50 years and run on everything from
spacex shuttles to the internet to
watches to smartphones to everything
else how long brendan would probably
have said oh
two weeks
what's a
smartphone so yes here are some
javascripty things um an empty array
equals not an empty array
according to type coercion no idea why
that is but but those two things are the
same
i think it's that empty array becomes
object which
is not null therefore it's true and not
empty array it coerces the array to zero
which is the size of the array and then
knots it so it becomes true so that's
true equals true equals true
who can spot what's wrong with this line
of code or why it does what it does
so
in the middle here
plus plus
so because javascript does type coercion
what it's actually trying to do here is
b plus a plus
and then we've got this plus floating
here and it goes well i'm already here
so this must mean plus a
so we're doing the positive value of a
i'll try and coerce a to a number so
that i can oh no it's not a number so it
becomes nan
type of nan incidentally is number so
not a number is a number um and then we
add the other ray on to it and so b plus
a plus plus a plus a is banana
because of course it is
um
and
douglas crockford wrote a book called
javascript the good parts um have you
ever seen the photograph of javascript
the good parts next to javascript the
definitive guide that's quite i took
that photograph
and i put that on twitter and this was
like back in
2012 or something um and it got 45 000
likes
and i was yeah i'm famous
but yes the difference between
javascript the good parts and javascript
the definitive guide is basically the
dom it's the document object model um
that is the bad parts of javascript
according to douglas crockford and he's
kind of got a point because uh
document.all which is all the elements
in in the document is an instance of
object but if you do type of
document.all it tells you it's undefined
so you go all right does document all
equal equal equal undefined and it says
no it doesn't and you go does this
document.all equal equal equal null no
it doesn't equal that either you go well
if you type coerce it does it equal
equal null and the dom go yeah yeah it
does
and
they can't fix it there are there is
code in the world that relies on that
behavior um and so java i mean i don't
know what the cost of javascript is but
the fun we have with it is priceless and
uh yeah i'm i'm just quite down with
that
um
so i would like to have some honorable
mentions here um heartbleed
that popped up a few years ago this was
a serious bug in openssl
which essentially rendered the whole
thing completely vulnerable to attack
and of course openssl is used by
everybody google microsoft amazon
facebook
apple everybody uses openssl and
everyone was like how could this be
allowed to happen and the you know that
xkcd cartoon of the entire modern
infrastructure of the world and a random
open source project somebody in nebraska
has been thanklessly maintaining since
1996. that was open ssl i was just like
this one guy who was maintaining this
thing that
multi-trillion dollar companies were
relying on and there was a bug in it and
none of them had thought to kind of give
this guy's code a read or check it out
or anything like that and then this year
we had log for j because it turns out
that one of the things you can put into
log for two is a log this log this
call to another service
and while you're logging this call to
another service pass it some information
again martin's thing earlier on about
baggage and log4j was very so you could
put something into a text field and then
log for
would log what you put into that text
field except it was a uri that said
execute a java enterprise b there's that
word enterprise again on this other
server and just pass it all the data
that we've got attached to this log
while we're at it and
there is not a single java application
in the world that is not using log4j
um so so that was fun and then they
fixed that one so i mean that wasn't in
java it was in a library that every java
application uses but it wasn't in java
itself so java looked okay for literally
two weeks
and then somebody looked at java's
actual in the box
ecdsa implementation so ecdsa is a very
complicated algorithm and it involves
three numbers
and
one number is the result of a sum and
the other number the other two numbers
if you multiply the first number by the
second number then it should equal the
third number
and so so that was fine
but it turns out that you pass these
three numbers along with your ecdsa
token this might be
a json web token or a saml token
something that you've encrypted using
the ecdsa algorithm and if you pass it
in and so you've got the numbers i think
they were p
um r and
uh and q p and r and so it's like p
times r equals q
um and so if you set q to zero and r to
zero then it did p times q and does that
equal zero yes it does and so literally
just by sending a malformed ec dsa
signature with these two values set to
zero you could get java to go yeah
that's fine
that was in the actual that's that's
like the base class library that was in
the jdk but that one came along that was
fun
so
so we've seen
some fun examples we've seen some very
very expensive examples
i would like to finish off with with one
example where we basically got lucky
that
yeah programmers make all these mistakes
we're fallible and we're sort of
hubristic and we're arrogant and we do
stupid things
fortunately
the rest of the world knows that and
they don't trust us as far as they could
spit a rat
and so
the soviet early warning system
uh in 1985
was switched on and almost immediately
reported that america had launched five
missiles against the uh the ussr
um it hadn't
what the image recognition software
running on i don't even know what kind
of computers the soviet union had in
1985 i'm guessing they they probably
involved rocks and and bits of elastic
but um
you know it wasn't great but when
they've launched five it was actually
the sunlight glinting off clouds but
that was incorrectly identified as the
rocket trail from intercontinental
ballistic missiles and this man
stanislav petrov lieutenant colonel
stanislav petrov on the 26th of
september sorry 1983 not 1985 was told
that five missiles were inbound to the
soviet union from the united states and
he should immediately launch the soviet
union's response he should immediately
launch what turned out to be all four of
their intercontinental ballistic
missiles and if he had done that then
the american early warning system would
have seen those and america would have
launched all the minutemen missiles that
eisenhower had built because he thought
that the russians had 4 000 icbms they
didn't they had four but he thought they
had four thousand so america had five
thousand and they would have launched
all of them and that would have been
game over humanity most life on this
planet and then in another fifty 000
years maybe there'd be a building here
with a software conference with highly
evolved cockroaches
talking about
programming's greatest mistakes but
stanislav petrov said
nah i don't believe that
i'm not launching missiles based on what
a computer says it can go stuff itself
and so we did not get world war iii on
september 26 1983 because there was a
human between the computer and the
missile launch system and thank god for
that because that very nearly cost all
known life in the universe and that's
how serious some of this stuff is
so yeah think about that as you go back
to work tomorrow or next week and maybe
just be a little bit more careful
thank you very much for listening to me
and i will see you next time
you